Looks like I used a sharpie marker for my eyeliner and apparently the roots are playing, today. new year, new me!
oh no
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know - your life is different now. It is the beginning of
2018 some say it's the beginning of the end - less Bloody Mary
Concept being more welcomed by more restaurants across
All the land. Last year was not my finest year. The year that my brother
And I were really obsessed with that show The Nanny was probably my *Fine-est* year you didn't get it
did you? *Mr Sheffield*. Okay, but this year I have really high hopes!
I have a niece named Hope and she likes to... She's got anxiety. No she's a baby
about drugs. Like, I think all of us want the beginning of any new year is to do better than the year before and I
Really, really want to do that. So I thought I would share with you guys, some of my new year's resolutions:
I want to regularly upload videos. Ouf, that's hard
Ow?
Yea, this guys not ready to be made into guac.
I want to try to experiment (oooh?) with formats (ahhh) like anal.
anal....(oooh?) ogous content. You know, maybe a scripted series. (ahh)
Or just porn. (argh?) I want to create more of a routine for myself (french fries cheese curds gravy). That's poutine. (just shitty millennial)
That's a poo-teen, (but like a bunch of them.) That's a poo-team (stop it!) That's a few, scene (this is stupid!)
That's a ew, meme. (Oh my god!) I want to start responding to things sooner. (Oh, that's good cuz you're terrible)
GO F*** YOURSELF...
*phone rings "my neck my back by Khia Simone plays *
That's your phone...That's your phone. That's you phone that's how  do i keep getting wedgies in the front
Want to start to get out of my comfort zone?
(Oh?!) but not like "I'm gonna start doing music" out of my comfort zone. Don't worry. (Oh thank god!) I mean like porn
(Oh, thank god!) I want to start taking better care of the things that I own. (Awh, that's good like your brain?)
ew, no. (your body?)
My what? (your dog....?)
She's here somewhere. (Okay, then what do you own that you are going to take care of?) my grudges.
I own so many of them, I just want to make sure that I take good care of them
So I can just maintain them forever
Oh, this year I also want to start to read more
*laughter*
*laughter turns to crying*
(no you don't!). no I don't
(No you don't)
I don't at all
(but porn though)
Okay, that's it for this video guys if you liked it
Please make sure that you subscribe because things are gonna change a little bit this year
I've been on YouTube for so long
And I'm just I'm I gotta change things up to make myself happy and hopefully you guys too? So my potential thought is that
*Burps* My body is functional, but also that for the last few years
I've been trying to upload videos Monday, Wednesday and Friday
So I thought let's change it up this year, and what about Tuesday Thursday? Doing three videos a week,
I've realized, has started to like hurt my heart and makes me less enthusiastic about posting so I'm hoping maybe two videos a week might
Clear my brain and give me more creative space to come up with some really fun things
So let me know in the comments down below
If you think Tuesday and Thursday are good upload days and let me know in the comments down below
what your new year's resolutions are whether they are true or not, just let me know because
I don't know. Home improvement could be a great name for a porn. I'm just saying